are humans actually responsible for
global warming we know that the planet
is warming and we know that CO2 is
responsible but how do we know that we
emitted that CO2 well there are
different isotopes of carbon carbon 12
carbon 13 and carbon 14. think of them
as like flavors of carbon different
objects that contain carbon contain
different mixes of flavor for example
plant matter has more carbon-12 in it
because that's more easily taken up in
photosynthesis carbon emissions from
volcanoes contain more carbon 13. carbon
14 is the interesting one because it's
radioactive and so slowly breaks down
over time as an object like a tree gets
older the fraction of carbon 14 in it
slowly decreases you may have heard of
radiocarbon dating over the past Century
the fraction of carbon 13 and carbon 14
in the atmospheres of flavor mix have
both decreased which tells us that the
source of extra carbon in the atmosphere
must have basically no carbon 13 or
carbon 14 in it and so is not volcanic
and must be very very old so old that
it's fossilized the only way to explain
how the atmosphere's carbon isotope
ratio is changing is extra carbon coming
from fossilized organic matter what we
burn as fuel